oui on a toujours entendu des phrases
bateaux oui le foot n'est pas fait pour
les femmes
allons-y alors
Christine Paris avec vous nous restons
sous le signe du charme et de vos
footballeuses françaises qui ont
rencontré les Norvégiennes
où elles sont et puis moi je voudrais
vous remonter ce soir je voudrais cette
misogynie parce que c'est complètement
ridicule on veut faire de la femme
sportive un sexe symbole on veut des
Catherine Deneuve des boderek et des
Ursula Andress surtout les terrains du
monde
pourquoi mais non parce que les
footballeuses non beaucoup après les
journalistes et je crois que et
finalement elles sont terrorisées elles
ont elles ne veulent plus voir de
journalistes elles sont complètement
terrorisées d'ailleurs vous allez le
voir
les footballeurs
c'est fou quand même c'est fou et moi
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour même si je
la connais pas mais pour ce genre de
femme qui qui se sont battus et sur le
plateau ils sont six contre la seule
femme donc ça démonte aussi l'évolution
qu'on a aujourd'hui dans notre football
les pionniers ont été très importantes
pour pour l'évolution du foot parce que
ils en ont pris elles en ont pris plein
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque c'était encore
beaucoup beaucoup plus dur même si je le
conçois pas mais c'était beaucoup plus
dur quand on voit nos pays voisins comme
l'Angleterre même l'Italie même
l'Espagne les Allemands qui se
développent et qui ont ce respect pour
pour le sport qu'on effectue parce qu'on
se réveille tous les matins comme les
garçons pour
travailler et donner le meilleur de soi
donc
peu concevoir qu'on n'apprécie pas mais
critiquer de la sorte nous femme on le
fait pas ça change mais il y a encore
beaucoup beaucoup à faire de générations
en génération bon ce doigt de continuer
à se battre pour pour les suivantes et
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
tout simplement
[Musique]
on a dit que pour venir à Barcelone le
transfert a été de 5 milliards de
centimes en francs est-ce que vous
pensez que ce n'est pas trop
je ne vaut pas 5 milliards
mais beaucoup plus
bah moi je me rappelle quand Karim il
était Benzema il était vendu à Madrid
était vendu 35 millions aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il serait vendu peut-être 150
on voit quand à peine 10 ans les
chiffres ils ont doublé voire triplé
mais
les joueurs ils sont pas entre
guillemets responsables de ça sur ce
côté là c'est de mon différent aussi
avec les féminines parce que bah c'est
tout récent on commence à entendre des
transferts des prêts avec option d'achat
etc c'est tout récent en 2011 on avait
même pas nos noms sur les maillots en
championnat et on sait très bien que
aujourd'hui un club fonctionne avec des
doigts TV un club fonctionne avec les
ventes de tickets de maillots donc les
sponsors aujourd'hui c'est compliqué de
pouvoir
revendiquer des sommes qui sont
impossibles pour pour les clubs à donner
[Musique]
et puis à la 60e le but de la victoire
sur un Français
[Musique]
à la tête
[Applaudissements]
elles ont gagné moins de Coupe de France
que de titres nationaux les
footballeuses de l'OL n'ont donc pas
boudé leur plaisir d'avoir reconquis
cette coupe que le PSG leur avait
soufflé l'an passé
et l'ouverture du score
pour l'équipe le deuxième poteau c'est
directement
le secret pour rester au plus haut
niveau si le travail moi je me lève le
matin je fais ce que j'aime ce que j'ai
toujours rêvé de faire depuis tout petit
donc
voilà tout le temps que j'aurai cette
force là cette mentalité là bah et que
le physique bien sûr suit mais je
continuerai oui il y a des moments où
forcément on loupe des choses en famille
mais après ça fait partie du job et on
l'accepte le but c'est de continuer à
inscrire son nom au plus haut niveau et
dans l'histoire de du football qu'on a
eu cette opportunité de pouvoir
remporter ce premier titre
malheureusement on est passé à côté
je suis passé à côté mais
j'ai vu aussi des grands joueurs pendant
des années travailler
pleurer après chaque compétition
internationale et qui ont réussi à
débloquer leur palmarès sur le Tarn donc
il faut continuer à travailler y croire
et puis après le jour viendra où il
viendra pas mais en tout cas c'est
toujours une fierté de représenter son
pays parce que c'est pas donné à tout le
monde
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on a fait ce qu'il fallait
pour lui donner une chance de devenir
de vrais stars d'avoir une vraie équipe
un vrai engouement avec le public et
puis surtout d'avoir un projet projet
c'était de venir la meilleure équipe de
France mais surtout de devenir la
meilleure équipe d'Europe ça c'est un
homme ça c'est respect ça c'est jusqu'à
ma mort il aura mon respect parce que si
je suis là aujourd'hui c'est grâce à ce
monsieur il y a aussi d'autres ce que
Farid ben City le premier coach kakouia
moi
il aurait dit non je serai pas là non
plus mais en tout cas le président là
s'il a été un visionnaire il a bien sûr
il y en a beaucoup qui parlent qui
disent oui c'est intéressant le foot
féminin mais lui il a investi il a
investi il a mis les moyens pour qu'on
puisse entraîner au quotidien et au fur
et à mesure des années je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il est très fier de sa
section en tout cas je pense qu'on est
un club phare on a un club qui a marqué
et qui marque encore l'histoire de de
notre du football maintenant voilà il y
a forcément de la concurrence et c'est
tout ce qu'on aime et c'est tout ce
qu'on apprécie donc
je pense qu'AVI on aura voilà le nom de
l'OL gravé sur les différentes trophées
ouh là là
en remontant la route nationale 2 tout à
fait vers le nord le long de la côte de
Caraïbes on arrive au bout du Prêcheur
son nom vient d'un ancien île
aujourd'hui disparu qui avait la forme
paraît-il d'un prédicateur en chair
c'est la dernière commune au nord-ouest
de la Martinique la route cependant se
poursuit au nord au milieu d'une forêt
tropicale jusqu'à l'anse ses ronds et
lance couleur elle s'étend sur près de
3000 hectares et compte officiellement
un peu plus de 2200 habitants
[Musique]
c'est là où est tout est parti donc
effectivement c'est la dernière commune
dans le après enfin dans le Nord
Caraïbes et une fois qu'on arrive au
prêcheur il faut faire demi-tour donc
fier de ma commune et fière de fier de
savoir d'où je viens quand on est enfant
et qu'on a pas connu ailleurs on sait
pas si ailleurs est mieux que ce qu'on a
en tout cas on fait avec les moyens
qu'on a on fait que les valeurs que nos
parents ils nous inculquent après c'est
sûr que quand on grandit j'ai eu cette
opportunité de pouvoir venir ici en
métropole et qu'on discute aussi avec
d'autres personnes et des enfants de du
même âge
on peut se dire bah oui peut-être que
ailleurs était mieux que chez nous à
partir du moment où je peux j'ai
l'opportunité
je descends parce que
j'ai besoin du soleil et le soleil le
vrai soleil je le trouve chez moi en
Martinique voilà
[Musique]
nous la bonjour aussi notre fête des
pères nous dont le nom est de souffrir
en silence seul sans soin et sans
réconfort plan de mort de salle
d'attente
nous qui inlassablement dansons des
biberons pendant des mois nous qui rend
dépit du dur labeur quotidien
entreprenons dès leur plus jeune âge et
à toute heure l'éducation de nos enfants
envers et contre tout nous qui savons
sacrifiés nos soirées pour nous dédier à
la culture de leur jeune intelligences
nous qui savons supporter dans la joie
de fracas de leur divertissement nous
l'avons enfin à notre fait
ah mon papa
il est parti tôt mais je pense que
j'avais huit ans et j'ai pu partager
aussi beaucoup de choses à avec lui et
malheureusement bah ouais c'est vrai
qu'il y a j'aurais pas fait qu'il soit à
mes côtés aujourd'hui mais c'est comme
ça c'est la vie et en tout cas
l'héritage il est il est plus que beau
et je pense que pas je pense je suis sûr
il est fier de ses enfants et forcément
il est fier de moi donc en plus j'étais
la dernière donc
ouais je j'étais tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps avec
lui je pense qu'il devait avoir marre de
moi je rigole mais non enfin là c'est
comme ça j'étais vraiment vraiment
proche de mon papa et c'est pour ça
qu'après le décès il y a des
gens de mon entourage même extérieur qui
pensait que
j'allais un peu dériver parce que bah
c'était mon guide en fait donc du coup
on perd son guide à très jeune même si à
la maman c'est compliqué il est toujours
là il est voilà il est parmi nous là
[Musique]
combien d'Antillais j'ai connu en France
quand je suis arrivé qui avait honte de
se dire antillais martiniquais ou
guadeloupé combien d'entre eux avaient
encore honte de l'Afrique et qui se
disait sud-américain oui ils étaient
prêts à être créés pas du tout la
qualité africaine
ça sacré sacré monsieur c'est dommage
perd son âme j'aurais bien aimé à le
rencontrer mais je suis beaucoup trop
jeune et il est parti beaucoup trop tôt
mais en tout cas quel héritage que
l'héritage qui a qui nous a laissé je
pense qu'il a
j'ai pas dire révolutionné le monde noir
mais pratiquement en tout cas il a il a
fait comprendre à au Mont Noir que bon
on est aussi important et qu'il fallait
prendre des responsabilités donc
voilà fier d'avoir eu un monsieur comme
comme celui-ci pour nous guider nous
emmener sur la bonne voie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut dire magnifique
la première fois où j'ai été appelé en
jeune et que je l'ai entendu et que je
l'ai chanté à lignée avec mes
coéquipières
voilà plein de plein de souvenirs le
moment où je l'ai partagé avec ma
famille quand la France a gagné en
France la Coupe du Monde voir le coq aux
entraînements ce qu'on a quand même la
tunique de notre pays donc non beaucoup
beaucoup d'émotions et beaucoup de
souvenirs et de bons souvenirs
et après il était impossible de revenir
ça allait trop vite devant
[Musique]
moi et le moral vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que vous abandonnez tout en face
c'est peut-être un petit peu exagéré le
cyclisme ça commence maintenant pour
vous c'est une déception
cela
fait de la peine
oui il y a des choses qu'on maîtrise il
y a d'autres sur le coup on est
ça nous passe au dessus de la tête ouais
c'est l'effondrement total parce que bon
on voit peut-être qu'on fait tant
d'efforts et que ça paye pas et on se
demande pourquoi moi et pourquoi pas
entre guillemets les autres
donc quoi il y a plein d'émotions qui
arrivent comme ça et
façon qu'à partir du moment qu'on
n'arrive pas à maîtriser ses émotions
c'est assez difficile et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on entend beaucoup les
sportifs de haut niveau parler de prépa
mental parce que il faut être capable de
se conditionner à ce genre d'épreuve
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a de plus en
plus de médiatisation il y a de plus en
plus de pression et si on n'est pas
costaud dans la tête pour ça c'est on
peut s'effondrer tous les jours après
aujourd'hui les sœurs Williams j'aime
beaucoup l'histoire parce que aussi elle
part de rien du tout et le père il a il
a tout fait tout fait pour limite un peu
les martyriser entre guillemets si je
peux dire mais c'est dans le bon sens du
terme pour pour
leur inculquer cette culture de la gamme
de dépassement de soi
[Musique]
ça signifie que je suis superstitieux
mais je tiens tout de suite à préciser
que pour moi la superstition c'est une
science
c'est une science il y a des gens qui
sont superstitieux comme d'autres par
l'anglais ou l'italien ou l'espagnol et
je suis devenu superstitieux le jour où
j'ai regardé dans un microscope
un jour comme ça un camarade m'a fait
regarder dans un microscope et j'ai vu
dans ce microscope des choses que mes
yeux ne voyaient pas et puis je suis je
me suis aperçu que mes oreilles
n’entendaient pas tout et que l'ensemble
de mes sens est illimité
alors à partir de ce moment-là je suis
devenu superstitieux parce que je me
suis dit vraiment ne pas être
superstitieux c'est une telle forme de
prétention c'est tellement croire que
l'on est un être suprême
puis à superstition permet de ramener
l'homme à sa juste valeur on va toujours
ranger son sac comme ça ses crampons
comme ça avant un match bah il y en a
vous mettre le côté gauche avant le côté
droit enfin il y a plein de choses et ça
c'est de la croyance et forcément vu
qu'on a répété ce genre de choses et
qu'on voit que ça marche bah à la fin ça
devient la superstition parce que on se
dit bah si je change peut-être que ça va
mal aller aujourd'hui donc
moi je partage à 70%
[Musique]
je sais pas quoi là
Bernard Pivot et enfin si Dieu existe
aimeriez-vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire bienvenue dans mon
royaume